good morning good morning everybody
Welcome uh to Berlin welcome to the NAT
hunda Museum uh where so happy to have
you here my name is C bambo and I'll be
your host uh this morning and I'll also
be moderating the
conversation uh this panel today or this
conversation is called East African
brins infused Berlin uh Brin City
Berlin and in this conversation we want
to explore the role of specialized
education centers in Eastern Africa and
southern Africa in fostering scientific
innovation and addressing space specific
Regional challenges using science so a
lot of the panelists and presenters are
working in these regions and they will
share with us their knowledge their
expertise and the works that they're
doing on the continent to Foster this
science uh community on the continent
and before we get into that I'll just
like to give a little bit brief
introduction about myself and my work
and uh we'll get a presentation about
black in Tech Berlin which is an
organization that founded here in Berlin
uh with the goal to collect n workor and
bring together the African and black
diaspora working in the technology
industry in Berlin and potentially we
want to also grow uh Germany wide and uh
and use that
influence I will say use that influence
for where but I would love to have the
presentation uh on the screen so you can
see where this is going but uh before
that welcome again and I hope you'll
enjoy the conversation today and if you
want to share this uh meeting right now
it's also live so if you go to science
week Berlin to this conversation there's
a link that you can share with somebody
to watch okay I just need to get the
remote to
go back and
forth yeah so that is black inter Berlin
this was our last meet up this photo and
it was actually a celebr cration of
Africa day every May uh we celebrate the
Day to try and see how the African
diaspora living in Berlin and Germany
can use their knowledge resources and
expertise to advance also the work
that's being done uh on the continent
and as you can see it says black in
Berlin but we also have a lot of people
also Brown and also we have a lot of
allies that identify with the cause of
our
organization and so our vision which was
just decided and um you want me to come
here ah you can't see ah okay
sorry uh so our vision we've decided to
uh put out this bold Vision to support
10,000 young African Professionals of
African
descent 10,000 young African
professionals to enter and succeed in
the technology industry by
2030 uh when I presented this Vision to
my uh to the to the group they actually
said why don't to say 1 million so I
just want to be realistic a little bit
and say 10,000 by 2030 but the idea is
we accelerate the work that we do we can
actually get to 1
million and again the goal and the
center the mission long-term is to unite
to empower to include and represent the
black and African professional working
in the tech industry in Berlin and
Germany if you've done a little bit of
research Berlin is the second largest
tech ecosystem in Europe after London
and I'm very hopeful that we can
actually overtake London now that they
are not not that the UK is not part of
the EU so we might as well overtake them
um in becoming the greatest so some of
our programs are focusing on networking
and community building coming together
to share ideas and experiences we also
focus on mentoring for career
advancement and so this is where we
provide a lot of coaching and skills
transfer from those that are very
experienced in the community to the ones
that are just entering the um the
industry or just starting out their
careers and lastly we create job
opportunities with our partners
corporate Partners here uh in Berlin and
make sure that the market is accessible
to the young black and African Talent uh
in the in the
market so our footprint uh we just start
with a little bit of research only three
to about 7% of professionals working in
the tech industry are black or African
and this statistic is actually based
from data collected in the US but I'm
hopeful that we can actually collect
data uh in the EU uh as time progresses
but this is the numbers that we're
dealing with um and also just in general
Germany has about only uh 1 million uh
of a population that identify of that
has African Roots so it's a very uh
limited number that might not get us to
the goal of reaching to 10,000 or 1
million if we do not connect to to the
African
continent but within this little uh
numbers uh we have a good footprint
right now in in Berlin and Germany we
have about 1,200 members on me.com we
have 400 members on our WhatsApp group
and we have 4,000 plus members or social
media followers right here in Berlin and
Germany so over the years starting from
2019 to now the the vision and the work
that we do is ging momentum and we want
to take this opportunity to continue to
accelerate the representation and uh um
inclusion of black and African uh
Professionals in the it
space and the reason why we're here
today is because this year we're
embarking on a project called Africa
Berlin Network and the idea idea of this
project is to create a sustainable
connected Network that Bridges the gap
between the Technologies ecosystem
between Berlin and Africa and so we're
so happy to be here to have you here in
Berlin to welcome you and the goal is
that in the course of the year and the
next years that we will continue to do
this with the networks on both side of
the continent so the project Focus will
be on exchanging of resources and
knowledge create a space for Berlin to
learn about the tech ecosystem in Africa
but also for the African Tech ecosystem
to learn about Berlin uh we're also
going to focus a lot on Talent
exploration and acquisition so this is
enabling Berlin based companies to learn
about the quality of talent that you are
developing on the continent and how that
can be beneficial to the businesses
either here or businesses that are
coming to open uh to open their branches
on the continent and we also want to
foster a network of investment for
ideas and this is where we will bring
investors from both side from Berlin and
the focused countries that we be uh will
be working in to exchange ideas and see
where can they invest on the continent
and also maybe where they can also
invest uh in
Berlin and we also want to connect
Innovation hubs uh this is very exciting
because Innovation hubs this is where
ideas that change the world are formed
and we know that in Berlin the tech Hub
the largest tech Hub what happens is yet
a lot of people are creating a lot of
innovation hubs are here creating the
solutions to possibly take Berlin and
Germany uh to the Future and we know
that this is happening also on the
continent so we want to create a space
where they can actually connect with one
another and learn from one
another and lastly we hope that this
project will able to increase cultural
understanding between the two regions
that we will have a good uh that Berlin
and Germany will have a good P
perspection about Africa the quality of
talent that's there the quality of the
tech ecosystem and at the same time
maybe also interest our young people
working um and developing their own
talent to take interest in Berlin maybe
um and see if this is this is a place
where they can build their own um skills
as well um as they accelerate their
careers in Tech and and so with that uh
I hope you're going to have a fruitful
uh conversation today you can ask me
about this project later um you can also
check out our website uh black in Tech
Berlin and we have information about
this project as well and um to that I'd
love to invite our next presenter Bard
fpra from Talent uh Terra
[Applause]
Talent thank you very much for uh
bringing me on the stage K uh thank you
for your presentation nice to see you
all here here in Berlin I think kave we
are both a little bit Berlin biased um I
am working or worked for the city of
berin for nearly um 20 years uh I think
you met some of my colleagues at Monday
morning at Berlin partner so I was
responsible manager for international
Affairs at Berlin partner and talent
acquisition and when it comes for this
Talent uh this International connections
there has been a strategy in Berlin for
years what kind of markets Berlin should
enter in in Africa as a continent was
never on the list and I think three
years uh uh back there was an
opportunity to create something like
what we call a watch list and on this
watch list we put Africa and then we
decided okay this Africa is too big
according to berin Berlin is only a city
and then we came up with four
destinations that it was Egypt that it
was Ghana East Africa and Sou Africa
where we have to dig deeper in and a
little bit the same the same topics like
um the startup scene The Innovation uh
background and and the talent uh for
that and we have been able to create a a
network the Africa bin Network and Cav
is
now going on further with that project
Now with an Tech Focus now it's burlin
Tech Network and this is like the basis
where we um Can can work on and uh with
the project before we have been able to
send delegations to Africa and this is
where we met with iua in um uh in Cala
that was like one of the first things
where we got in contact and now I'm so
super happy that you are here and have
this sort of a second step of
cooperation and I would love to see that
there is more cooperation coming
on um I think there are so many
possibilities of uh uh of of cooperation
um you already met I think a lot of
potential Partners stakeholders here in
ber and in Germany I just came up for
this small presentation like three
levels of Corporations I just name it
students academic and institutions as we
have here a scientific background um and
this is a little bit of personal view
from my uh perspective when we look on
where the students in Germany are coming
from at least Berlin Bas the biggest
Community here in Berlin are the
Indians uh you see the numbers there
have been a lot of people coming from
China this is now going down just
because of international policies and
things like that but there is already
some
Talent pipeline coming from Africa and
uh last year we see the first time that
there have been more Talent from Africa
coming to to to berin then from Brazil
and Brazil used to be a big Hub here in
Germany too I was a little bit surprised
that Cameroon was number one I don't
know why I have no reason to ask a
colleague of mine where that come from
Morocco I guess guet is doing some
project with them so guet is I think one
of those drivers perhaps where people
are coming from and the third one was um
Egypt I guess but you see that the
numbers in total are quite small when it
comes for this kind of of uh um facts
and Figures it's always interesting that
for example the IND Indians they come to
Germany or to Berlin for studying so the
first entry is studying and after
studying then going and find a workplace
that is for example different for
Brazilians Brazilians do not study in
Germany they came originally for working
here so and I think this is a difference
where I see there is a lot of
possibility still to have the student
Exchange in both directions so once I
visited a university in um Kigali and
they have a huge entrance hall that was
a
pretty
lovely looking place and for every
student from every country they put a
flag so there were a lot of flags in
this entry hall but there was no flag
from Europe so that means there is no
student from Europe doing a masters
whatever in Kigali and this is I think
this where we have to work on in both
directions to bring Europeans or Germans
to Africa and have their master degree
whatever uh thesis Innovation internship
in Africa and white wether though this
is one of those levels of Corporations I
see had tried to find out some some uh
figures on academic cooporation in in in
in in Europe and you again see that the
numbers for academic stuff and
professors for uh North Africa or uh
subsaharan Africa are slow compared to
others so there is much room to
Improvement to get this kind of
collaborations uh to to become closer
and
bigger um again I know that what's going
on in berin but I think you have
corporations all over Germany so there
is something going on in in the end but
the total numbers are not that uh that
big so the last slide in that sense
institutional cooporation I don't put
something in that because this is I
think where we have to discuss so I know
that there is a lot of things like uh
there is with the Technical University
in berin with the Heart TV uh uh un
University of applied science they have
an East African Hub already they try to
came up with a blockchain conference
together with a conference in Adama um
Ethiopia so I know that we have a German
University in Egypt so this is for me a
a very good example why we do not have
more German universities on the
continent because that brings uh a lot
of potential in in corporation we have
the G that with all those kind of
projects we have the federal employment
agency there are there are a lot of
stakeholders where we can build
corporations but this is why I see that
uh this kind of uh conference now is
perhaps a starting point to fill that
slide with a lot of examples when we
need meet next time to have uh this kind
of pilot projects and uh developed
project where we see okay Corporation
has started and is
growing this is my my last slide Terra
Talent I'm just sort of say resigned
from my job for the city of bolog and
now set up a company where we try to
build these kind of bridges between
especially Africa and German business
the German midle stun because I think
there are so many opportunities and this
is uh why I'm happy to be here and now
I'm looking forward for the rest of the
uh conference thank you very
much thank you Bart that was really nice
if you have questions you can ask him
after he'll be
here so our next presentation I'd like
to invite uh Dr salom guu from the inter
city un from the inter University
Council for East Africa welcome
so no
no good morning
everyone we are waiting for the
presentation to be
roaded no this is a long
one
maybe briefly I should be introducing to
you what is a interuniversity council
for East Africa oh the presentation is
already there this is an organization of
East Africa community and uh we handle
issues of uh Education and Research
within the community but for this
purpose we' be sharing some of the
research and Innovation programs that
we've been Harding together with various
partners
and even U part of the universities that
are here and this is a case of eastern
and southern Africa high education
centers of excellence project this is a
project that is implemented by 16
universities within um Africa of course
it's even beyond the East Africa and um
at un interuniversity Council for East
Africa we actually the the the the the
project facilitating uh unit uh for the
for this project it's actually funded by
the World Bank and we also have other
various projects dealing with u centers
of excellence briefly to highlight about
this project uh as I've mentioned being
a regional project it it's tackling key
among the key challenges and these key
challenges are the issue of inadequate
number of skilled graduates so it's
issue of capacity building issue of um
enhancing research output and uh so that
it can be impactful to the region and
also addressing there's also a challenge
of um Academia and Industry Partnerships
how do we strengthen that including
strengthening um even if it's not the
big Industries the small and micro
Enterprises also within the region and
also the growth of issues of
Entrepreneurship and startups and so for
this project the key overall goal like
I've said it's um to sustain growth of
course to reduce poverty within the
region and at the same time this can be
it's fed through skilled um capacities
it's about capacity
building and key Focus area for these
projects are five we focusing on uh
industry development issues of
Agriculture issues of Health uh
education and of course uh issues of
Applied statistics issues of data data
because you know data is very key if you
are to touch on the key components uh
for developmental growth so I'll
highlight among the very key
achievements especially progress the
project started uh from 2016 it's still
continuing and among these key issues uh
within the 16 universities there has
been establishment of um 16 centers of
excellence within the different priority
areas and within the eight across the
eight countries that are of interest for
this project and um for purposes of
capacity building uh
262 accredited academic programs you see
to to have a quality uh higher education
have also to have a very targeted and
strategic programs that are addressing
the challenges within the priority areas
and so the progress the program has
managed the project has managed to
achieve within this University's uh uh
strategic project uh uh programs for
capacity building and out of this
throughout the period we've achieved
over 7,000 postgraduate um students and
this includes Masters and PhD across the
the the six prior the five priority
areas and one of the key issues is also
the charge especially of inclusivity
especially the women and so we highlight
the importance of having women also in
the in the Capac in the higher education
training and we have uh out of these
7,000
35% is a female and this is quite an
achievement because we don't want to see
that um even women being left behind and
of course being an academic component we
also mentioned about the Publications
because for us to reach out and partner
with um other people in the region uh
science from the region from Africa from
East Africa at large it also has to be
felt by others with across the world and
so uh publications of
3,600 out of the work that have been
done so far and this is a very good
indication because we also to want to
see that um whatever is happening within
the region even academical is being felt
out there and also uh people in the grob
can access what is being done within the
region and of course we would say there
are is direct and indirect project
beneficiaries this is academically this
is uh also in terms of the students this
is in terms of also the technical uh
support uh staff within their and this
over 20,000 we' say they are project
beneficiary out of what is really
happening and um highlight specifically
for this project um four incubation
centers have been um so far established
and they are running and um some these
are among the four one in Uganda which
is uh mainly dealing with uh farmer and
uh traditional medicine issues which is
at barara University for Science and
Technology there's a data driven
Innovation Hub uh at Nelson Madera and
uh we have another one at Mo University
in Kenya which is also dealing with
phytochemicals textile uh um issues and
then there's one on energy grid
Innovation incubation Hub at the
University of Ronda this is just a
highlight of one project but I would
also give you that to show that I at
inter University Council being in the
region it's also hard during um these
are mostly the success drivers for these
uh centers of excellence the is um you
have first of all to focus on issues of
organization and the leadership the
financing model is uh that of
um it a way that um it's um output res
based uh project uh the financing model
and of course there is a very clear
monitoring and evaluation systems that
are ongoing but the key thing is the
focus of strengthening Partnerships and
these Partnerships are about industry
Academia public private and engaging as
most Partners as possible and that's
what we are seeing that it will able and
the growth and also sustainability of
these and I would also like to highlight
because uh of course we we are here in
Germany and it's very important also to
highlight we work very well with German
partners and we have another Center of
Excellence which is at Nelson Madera uh
Nelson Madera African Institute for
Science and Technology and we also have
them here and this project it's for
Center of Excellence for ICT in East
Africa and um with this I'm sure you'll
get more details about this Center and
we are working collaboratively with um
GIS and also the focus of this apart
from the capacity building on ICT that
is specifically especially on embedded
mobile systems we are focusing of
strengthening the regional networking
with for the East Africa institutions
and this is about the the universities
within the region how can they work
together because togetherness
partnership is power and not just that
there's a focus on the best practices of
engaging Academia industry and in this
program uh actually for the students who
participate in this they have actually
are very clear linkages they they have
to have a component within an industry
and uh now from this project we are also
trying to strengthen the component of uh
the incubation centers especially to n
the innovations that are coming out from
the students which are coming from this
U uh program under the Senate and uh
with that I'll say thank you and within
the next Pro uh presentation I believe
that Nelson Madera will actually tell
you more details about um this Center
and what they are really achieving thank
you very much
Dan amazing thank you so much for your
presentation thank you so we gonna have
a panel discussion uh afterwards and uh
people can ask questions thank you
amazing thank
you so I would love to invite our next
speaker for the uh next
presentation Professor Michael kisang
Kiri please come on
stage this one
next hello
everyone this
right yes I'm going to present about the
center of excellence for ICT in East
Africa H my name
is s Micha I'm the center leader h i was
supposed with
my of the school of C Dr must Ali but we
agreed that he would be on the in the
later session
yeah those are the contents but before
presenting about the center I talk about
the nise thism is a university where by
this Center is
hosted uh NM is
a it's called n Mandela African
institution of Science and and
technology is a center which is at Aria
Tanzania and it is formed because of the
idea from Nation Mandela and the our
former president
Julius and the main objective of Center
is to cut for the research which will
help the that area to deal with the
challenge of the community and the and
the
industry yeah so the NY have three
schools and we have a school of the lisb
which deal with the L sciencey School of
the Bush which deal with the
business and humanity and M deal with a
lot water and energy and and Co deal
with I Cox is a school which is hosting
the center of excellence for ICT a
senate and as you see the the model
there is that uh the nms as it is it act
as as an engine of producing Solutions
of the challenge which are facing a
society and and Industry so when this
Sol a challenge uh passing through nise
later on we have Solutions so that is a
model which I mean we are we are
practicing at
n yeah so the next SL is about the co
about the program which at the co and
and then in this program we have
embedded and mobile system which is Emos
and and Emos is that is a program which
is conducted by the by the center of for
excellence that is the Senate and how it
is
formed H Senate it is formed by the uh
ger government and East African
Community but it's a key objective is a
is to to cut for the I Solutions which
will help the key economic area of East
Africa because after the H study which
is conducted on 2017 it was found that
there's a key economic area of of in
East Africa they are lacking I skills so
that's why African Community and German
government came with an idea of starting
a center which will will upscale the I
skill I te knowled of the young people
within the East African
region so the center has got Partners we
have partner in Germany and also we have
partner in East Africa so each country
country in East Africa has one
institution which which is a partner to
the to the Senate so we form something
called Consortium of University whereby
some activities of the centers we
working together because it is the East
African Center of Excellence so it's
owned by the by the East African
States so this is a model which we are
following as a as Emos I mean it's that
program which is for embedded and mobile
system uh our our program it is very and
highly connected with the industry a
students is spending only two semester
at the university whereby is being a
coach and give skills and knowledge and
then the the remaining two semester is
connected with the
industry whereby first of all we start
to um engage in a group project where
three of student they're working
together they're giving some topic and
then come up with a solution and then
after that they go to the Outreach
whereby they visit the industry and they
look at the challenge facing the the
industry and then after after H got an
idea how to come out with the solution
they come to ask at n Mandela and they
defend that that idea and when is they
being allowed and approved then they
have been engaged in that internship and
that internship it is the final report
is used as
a as their final project so when it is
successful then there will be given a
degree so this you'll find that each
degree H from that Center is a solution
either to the community or to the
industry so that's the model which we
are using at the as the
Senate yeah so this is show
that how that the Senate is doing this
model whereby a very strong
collaboration with the industry and the
area which we are really collaborating
is on curriculum development joint
research student internship and
knowledge exchange and initiative so we
are always H engag in of giving lecture
and even on on teaching make sure that
the student while they studying also
they'll have some knowledge or skills or
what is going on on the industry so
after graduating when they're being
employed they'll not be new about the
what activities which are going on on
the industry so this is the kind of
model which we are using at the at the
center so those are the pillars of the
Senate which one of them is the master
degree of ER which is of Emos second one
is the partnership partnership with
industry and partnership uh with the
institution across the the region and
the third one is the training so we are
also giv training to some of institution
if for example institution is coming to
to our Center telling us that they are
lacking some skills whether on cyber
security Machin learning and so on so
what we are doing is that we create a
short training I mean it is a taor made
I mean that we come we discuss the area
which they are missing some skills then
we create that a training and giving
them so those as a key as a key pillar
uh our master degree program partnership
and also training the community and and
Industry within the
region so the center has a lot of
achievement I don't know if you can read
there yeah first of all we have a
successfully host Ed five cohort uh of
in total around 146 students of which
112 we have we given scholarship and and
37% of them were female I think that
this is one of the most successful H
institution in East Africa whereby we
have
37% uh of the of the I mean a student
which are female because remember that
this Emos is about science and
technology so to have female 70% in
engaged in science technology is not
something
easy and also we have established active
industrial uh Corporation with some of
the key company industry within East
Africa that was not easy because in East
Africa indust just have Habit to shy to
collaborate with the university but we
tried it a lot and with the help of gsz
we have secure about five h i mean mou
but that not enough we want more and
more and also we have conducted summer
schools and next this month also WECT
the the fourth one so each year we
conduct one one summer school and also
we did capacity building we did also
several guest lecture from the industry
and last year we had our first
International Conference on
technological advancement in embedded
and and the mobile system we called it
eor OS where student project and outputs
were showcased and and also uh
published so we have several of them
these are others whereby also
we've with the two Innovation hubs of
stub and West Val H yesterday I came to
know that West Val is also here in
Germany but they branch in in in ARA
Tanzania so we we soon have with them to
help our student in development of their
Innovations uh and also we have
established the support NS Alum Network
yeah andou with
universities so here I just want to
showcase very few a project which were
done by by your student as I said it
before that they are come to to H to H
to our institution to gain skills these
student most of them they very good idea
very talented but the only problem which
they have is a tution fee to be engaged
into the university I know here in
Germany uh I mean I mean universi is
free you don't have to pay tuition fee
but there in Africa you have to pay and
based on the economic standard of the
people there yeah you know if does not
get a scholarship it will be very
difficult for to have those I mean
brains some people is very bra I mean
very talented a lot of I mean skills but
because coming from the poor family it
will be very difficult to to get them so
this is one is one of the example of the
student who say is from Ronda says that
his village was very close to the uh to
the national park so there's a problem
there whereby animals were coming to the
village and eat the I mean invading the
plantation I mean and eat everything so
this will cause a problem hungers and so
on so this student get an idea what can
what can I do so he found that those
animals which are coming to their
plation in Ving all of them they being
eaten by lions okay so they feding lion
so what he did he created an a I mean I
mean a an H Gadget
whereby ER with a sensus so when it it
found that some animals is approaching
the village so that Gadget it generated
the voice of
lion okay so those animals run away so
it created something like I can say is a
vual fence because before the authority
put a physical fence and this physical
fence fence sometimes it was hurting
animals when they are forcing thems into
the village so he put the the vual sense
by using the voice of Li so when they
approaching when that they head The
Voice those animals are running away so
in this case that animal are safe and
the village were safe all of them were
happy and this is another project which
are done by our student you know in in
East Africa we are using a motorbike as
a as the tax mainly we call it b b okay
but is there's any issues there issue of
theft and then issue of the charging so
those student they say what can we do to
solve this problem so they come out with
a prototype whereby is only it allow
only the driver to to whatever to put on
the the the motorbike by using bio
biometric even the face recognition and
and also uh that prototype uh it has
artificial intelligence whereby it can
detect the condition of the road because
when this motorbike are passing in the
tamak road they use less petrol than the
rough road you know there we don't have
all over to Road like here there's a lot
of rough road there but them they don't
know that in a in a rough road that
motorbike use more more fuel than
compare with the TAC road so by using
this one when is that artificial
intelligence it detects that now B is
passing through the toak road it lower
the rate rough road it increase the rate
to make sure that that driver is getting
the fair I
mean money because otherwise you you
cannot I mean take that rough road and t
Road all of them doing the same fuel so
this is a solution also being created by
one of our student it's a very good
solution it is there
on our
lab so at the end I want to talk about
the challenge which which we are facing
which uh is C is facing Center has a a
lot of I mean planning but one of the
key challenge is the industrial Academy
relation as I said before that is not a
culture in East Africa whereby industry
collaborated with University but we did
a lot of of effort but we need more
collaboration the second one we need
more IND from the region and Beyond
Center need to collate with more
industry within the region and also
beyond the region so as we can do
collaborative research and then we can
learn from them because I know that H in
like in Germany we have Hightech which
we really need them in in Africa in
order to use it to solve the challenge
which is facing our our community over
there and he also H incubation most of
these ideas they at the end they left as
a lab so they need incubation to excel
them into the uh setup into the
commercial product where student can can
benefit on the work your Innovation
which did okay so we need I mean the uh
we are working hard to get incubation
fund so as some of the key or those very
important prototype to be esed into the
commercial product and the last one
about to have the state of of the art
laboratory so as to make sure that those
which will being developed there will be
those one which can be tested everywhere
because no student we have a lab but our
our lab is is a normal one but if we get
most advanced one then will be much
helpful for the uh for the
Center thank you very much
[Applause]
very
much and
um thank
you I've been inspired by these
presentations have you also been
inspired yeah thank you to all the
presenters maybe give them a hand of
Applause
again you know part of the description
that we have in this conversation is
African science for African Solutions
and I'm so glad that in the last
presentation we took a list of graphs of
two uh solutions that are actually
addressing two of the challenges of our
communities or the community of the
young person who build it and this is
the purpose of this discussion that we
need to start developing solutions that
actually speak you know to the
challenges that we have on the continent
but it wouldn't hurt to also develop
solutions that other people across the
world can use so I I feel like we are
already on the on the right path and
with the right partners and with the
right collaborators I think we will get
there so we'll now have a panel uh where
uh we will Explore More this topic and
you'll also get a chance to ask
questions to our speakers so I'd love to
call on our
panelists we're gonna have I think I
will still call to the stage uh Dr salom
back and I'll also uh like to call again
Dr kisang as well well um Prof also on
stage and then we will have two more
panelists I will stand don't worry so I
will stand on the side um we have either
a Prof uh fortunate miambi
not Dr fortunate is
here okay and then we have uh do uh Prof
OAS manona
please come on stage and we have Nelson
bonifas Prof Professor Nelson
bonifas okay so Daniel was going to join
us as well but you can just come to the
front as Daniel and we will pass the
microphone to you oh you
Daniel so we'll just pass the microphone
to you since we don't have uh so much
space on stage and I think our two
speakers need a microphone as well so
you we we don't want you to fall
uh Dr salom we don't want you to fall
down I think I think you can come here
so you can bring your chair
here
make you go back a little
bit so I I come on the other side
door
yes okay amazing thank
you African solutions for African
problems well this is not an African
problem it's just a stage problem right
here uh so once again thank you so much
for being here uh we're so inspired by
the work that you are doing on the
continent and again as uh professionals
and Community leaders building in the
tech technology industry uh and the St
space we are so happy to see that you
already building that capacity and again
this conversation is African solutions
for African problem
um we have a lot of challenges on the
continent but I also foresee that we
have a lot of opportunities to grow and
I first want to start with the
opportunities and chances that you've
seen through this program that you're
running across the the countries that
you're operating and uh uh Dr salom you
can wait and you can wait so I'd love to
pass on the question to
you
yes what are some of the opportunities
and um positive aspect that you've seen
because of this work in the countries
that you operate
in it's on it's on you can just speak
here thank you so much I am
proas director first of
wundi U through
presentations we noticed that uh in
Africa we have many opportunities and we
have many
talents and in this way uh I see that we
are focusing on solving problems we are
Focus facing up and that collaboration
is still a good way to achieve our
goals
uh however I can um add that we still
have problem of training many uh young
people and after they still have no job
after universities it's still a
challenge for our youth and our
population however uh if universities
and countries are together they can
solve many problems and uh the
technology is there to help us uh uh go
on going forward thank you okay thank
thank you so much and Daniel we spoked a
little bit earlier uh about what you're
doing on the continent and given the
fact that I spoke a little bit about the
diaspora uh in Europe working in the
stem uh industry or are operating in
that area what sort of possibilities do
you see that we could influence or we
could contribute to the work that you
doing yeah thank you so much uh it's
true that I had the global diaspora for
the randan community abroad and
when I saw the presentation going on I
found that there are many opportunities
that our diaspora Especial on the
continent of Africa together on the
Europe and especially on the barin side
we would bridge the gap of the knowledge
sharing there is a lot that the Africa
has and can learn and also there is a
lot the Europe has so through using our
diaspora networks can also bridge the
gap because I came to realize that if
even you look at what is being conserved
here most of those animals those are the
ones I believe they came from African
continent so when you look at the the
knowledge the the diaspora has would
create would bridge the gap between the
investment and also the gaps that we
need to bridge uh reason being that when
we collaborate with our diaspora Network
we already collaborating with with the
government indirectly because these are
the same networks that are reporting to
the ministries of Foreign Affairs and
also they are looking at the
opportunities they should be the I mean
the bridge between uh barin and also the
our respective countries uh I would give
an example that most of our Foreign
Affairs Ministries they have already
established a diaspora desk and the this
diaspora desk that is there even at the
East African Community level where
uh we have also established EU and also
the uh East African Community diaspora
we want the technology and Innovation uh
not to be left behind as the region so
in so doing the collaboration between
our region and our using our diaspora
would be easier uh the reason is that
these are the in people who are dealing
with indigenous groups or within the
within the grassroot here so when you
look at like now uh if you remember
before coid we had what you call R day
in in Bor and it brought all the
investors and all African diasporas and
it attracted all East Africans and the
German Industries together with the East
African Industries they were together
interacting through the diaspora so I
wanted to say that we can also expand
this uh collaboration for the Sans like
barin Sans uh to also penetrate within
our diaspora networks because they are
the ones who know our our challenges and
our opportunities back home and the same
again they have already identified the
opportunities we can take back so that's
the bridge I see in between that using
our diaspora can also resolve the gaps
that we have identified between uh this
side of the Europe and the side of the
Africa thank you thank you so much
Daniel uh my next question is for you Dr
salom and you you spoke a little bit
about the impact that you've had on
attracting women or female students into
your program do you have uh an example
of what strategies you use to actually
get those
37% and also what are why is it that you
find that women are not uh initially
attracted to join uh the tech or the
stem programs that you run well for the
for the women uh especially to encourage
them you have to we have a very
strategic and targeted uh way in that um
if it's a scholarship opportunities
especially for higher education you we
have specific calls that we say this is
a specific call for women and uh this is
not really toow the bar in any way
because there are women who are
qualified but uh sometimes they are they
they tend not really to a prise so we
have specific targeted call for
scholarship for women so that you try to
raise the numbers and uh if you allow me
also to comment on one of the key
opportunities that I see in these um uh
in these uh kind of um programs and uh
how do we it it's an issue of uh
utilizing the creative and
inquisitive youth we know we have very
creative inquisitive and incre ing
number of Youth in the region who are
ready to run so it's opportunities on
how we can engage them further I had to
bring that on thank you so much for that
answer um I'll just take this next
question to you Prof kangari and that is
on the challenges that you mention
around industry and Academia
relationships but also you talked about
incubation um in Berlin we have a lot of
incubation hubs and I'm so happy that
you actually have at least some
incubation hubs uh in some of the
countries that you work with um Are
there specific focused that these
incubation hubs look at and can you give
us examples so maybe like iot or AI like
what are the focuses of these hubs that
you you have okay thank you very
much thank you very much for the
question yeah Er When I was talking
about incubation as I said before that
those students
I think we have more than 100 students
and the and most of them they come out
with
Innovations so there at n Mandela
African technology we have a incubator
but to engage in student in the
incubator you need a fund number one and
number two also you need to H connect
him or her uh to the May to the industry
or or any people for example which are
dealing with them uh marketing
because yeah uh because not all
Innovation can go to the market you know
so we need also coaching of the student
make sure that the product which you are
up
scaling what kind of features which is
needed so as it can be ATT there into
the market so we need like
infrastructure I mean different I mean
field whereby can coach the student and
can keep the student because we know
that the student have already finished
studies so the Finish studies need to
leave okay so that kind of support the
one which I talking about and do you
have examples of what type of products
maybe comes out of the Innovation hubs
s any type of products that you had come
out of the Innovation hubs yeah uh I
mean so far at n Mandela as as
institution uh we have one product that
called Nan nter
whereby staff Mandela what they they
whatever they innovating like a filter
for the water because the water there
has some kind of of chemical which when
kids are drinking later on they affect
their their teeth okay okay so like
fluide like something like fluide in the
water so one of the the stuff and the
student came out with a fter called Nan
fter which it fit out that fluide and
makes the water to be safe for for for
drinking okay so that's the one of the
product from Innovation from that H
amazing thank you and for you Prof I'd
like to ask in terms of the caliber of
talents that's coming in general out of
these programs that you're um you've
created uh do you see that re reaching
the demand or meeting the demand of of
partnership for example in Germany uh
how do you manage to kind of uh see the
balance in terms like okay our students
have developed to this capacity but
Germany is looking for this standard and
let's try and meet the standard of what
potentially our partners could be and
perhaps Germany is just an example but
maybe you have other countries that you
partner with yeah thank
you thank you so much welcome and
actually first of all we have a pool of
candidates and we have proper
infrastructure to train those in ICT
agriculture business and
Engineering the way I see the
development of
um science in Berlin we have visited
some of the institutions here is very
high and uh if you go back to our
countries for instance areas of great
potential which is agriculture for
instance we have a lot of of products H
at the universities we have a proper
infrastructure where we set these kind
of skills teaching students agriculture
if you connect them with business uh we
could actually assist those students to
innovate and our staff to change the
product that we have for instance we
have the problem of um uh preserving
products like if I take examples of
tomatoes oranges bananas they are not
yet preserved even to be used after the
Harvest so that you have banana
throughout the
market um of the year in All Seasons
after the season ends then the bananas
won't be in the market or grapes or
oranges Etc now to meet the standards of
Europe we need first to learn how to
preserve those but we have started for
instance there
are live examples we have a will of the
government of Germany working together
with the government of Tanzania and now
we have for instance a project a
collaboration a collaboration between
the School of Business at the University
of daram and agriculture with tu Berlin
trying to preserve those kind of
products so that probably in future they
can meet standards and penetrate the
market of the European Union through
those kind of
establishments thank you so much much my
last question before I give to the
audience is around research um a lot of
the products that we see come out to
Market in Europe at products and
solutions that have been spent a lot of
time into research so most Founders or
or products that are sold like starting
from a PhD research and then it's taken
into an incubation H program and then it
comes out to to the market how strong is
our research um our research fac
facilities our research programs and
perhaps maybe this opportunity is giving
you a space to see how further you can
take the research programs that we have
so that we actually thoroughly invest in
studying the the the problems that we
have and the solutions that we
potentially want to take out to
Market how strong is our
research or if it's not what is your
overview of the next coming two years
what should we look forward to can yeah
uh thank you so much uh to my
understanding and to the little I have
seen our research is still low and not
because that our universities are not
able but it's because of the policy so
when you look at our national policies
and the regional policies the value they
give our professors our schools and
dominations behind that it's the one
that is really affecting the research
period so the whole ecosystem goes with
what is the output at the end of of the
day so if the I see the synergies from
the political side uh the Academia and
also uh the supporters of the initiative
to come together and becomes the
national policy so the few research
centers we have visited here and even
elsewhere within the Europe you would
see that there is the government support
there is the commitment behind that so
uh it's not that our professors and our
students are not
but because there is a little time given
so what is the take home it's now the
advocacy to see how do we do our
homemade solutions within a research and
how do we Engage The politicians to
understand that it's important that
there is a strong maturity within
research otherwise most of our
researchers within the space die
prematurely because you have started an
innovation it is even sometimes is taken
to the Europe Asia and El where and our
professors suffer because of there is no
reminition behind so the advocacy that
we have to do at the regional level
political level is how much time how
much remunerations do we bring behind
this and how should this impact our
Economic Development because they should
all know that it has an impact on the
economic development so the moment we
tie both together and show that the
research we do in our universities has
an impact on economic development and
transformation of a Nation then it will
follow the maturity and we reach at the
end of the results so that's at the view
of the region the esa and at the
personal level that's the way I see this
thank you thank you so much I'll now
open the floor to the audience to ask
some questions um if there any that came
to your mind yes we have one hand there
so I'll pass on the
microphone
thanks hi my name is Bastian I'm um
based in Nairobi and co-founded two
startups there so my question is a bit
more regarding Private Industry and um
technology companies so in Nairobi we
have like big International companies
like um Amazon Microsoft Google who came
there and set up big Development Centers
and I don't really see that and that
extent from European or German companies
um I'm not sure if any of you is like uh
involved like in the more industrial
side of things but do you know of any
efforts to also get European companies
to set up development Tech um creating
jobs there um that's my first question I
have another question um I also know
some people from the Kenyan AI um
practioners and research community and
not all of them are affiliated with uh
universities but there's quite a lot of
activity going on like independently um
what kind of
facilities or um positions can you offer
like independent people that are just
enthusiastic and do their own research
to maybe work together with them and uh
push things on that side
thanks thank you for your
question do you remember the
questions so anyone of you can feel free
to
answer I guess from the the the the
first question is like there are uh a
lot of private compan setting up offices
in uh uh in Kenya for example but
they're more American so do you know why
we don't have uh European or German
companies trying to set up centers in um
the countries that you operate in maybe
uh For Me Maybe to comment not to know
why the they are more Americans or why
they are more uh they are no there are
few Germans but uh to me I look at it
it's more of um that a proactive
approach even at bilateral levels within
the countries where even most of this
they also get in through even through
the the foreign Affair initiative and
I've seen most of the uh most of the
initiative actually as much as the
private they also come at that uh level
where even you can have even Forum
initiatives
uh private companies they they are
trying also to engage the local academic
world or the local hubs within the
region and it's a a country driven um
they come in batally and also helped
through the Foreign Affairs service yeah
so I I I I hope I've tried really to
provide I can add on on that uh as the
staff of the region uh one of the reason
why we have seen more American companies
coming to to the our region East Africa
and such when we deal with the trade
agreements like the trade agreement
today we have of the EPA the European
one takes care of the whole 27 European
countries instead of the count specific
and when you look at the trade agreement
we have that we have dealt with there is
America on a batal basis as she has
mentioned but there is also the EPA that
we did as the whole Europe as an at that
level so in the private sector there is
that vocal engagement but the reason is
that for us who have been also
attracting some of the European
companies there have been limited skills
uh in terms of what the they are
targeting in but this is what the the
universities are now solving with the
support from the gz and also bmz in
terms of building up the centers of
excellence like our master's program
last time when we were dealing with that
with attracting the European companies
especially even in Pharmaceuticals you
would see Indian companies are there but
the European companies they are just
supplying there is that mistrust of the
local of the local content so I believe
the establishment between the barin tent
and the East Africa with our inter
University Council would show them that
we have a talent within the region there
is the level of scrutin that they go
deeper to analyze which Americans don't
do and Asians so I just wanted to uh
inform anyone who is in the private
sector to see the way they can go and
follow the same Trend because at the
government level Europe is more dealing
with our governments you would see how
the
our like the president of here was
already in Tanzania the chancellor they
are there all at the political level but
when when it comes to the business I
think also the level of the quality
Europeans need uh needs to be uh
educated more because I have come to
realize that not only in Kenya but it is
within the whole region that there is
Indian penetration American penetration
Asian penetration China but Europe
because they wanted more skills but the
inter University Council together with
nelon Mandela has solved the case of the
gaps now which would now show the
Germans and others that we now have the
skills that people can now use because
even the Lev there is one of the
software company sry to say because I'm
also on the software side we were giving
them the programmers they are coming
from Europe of the company I will not
mention uh but when they looked at the
degrees of our our our staffs from
Nairobi university university of daram
other they say no they are not
accredited in our system so that is the
level we want to raise awareness so that
at least our our our universities can be
recognized that they can also be on the
market to compete while the Americans
for them they don't mind all they need
is output and asan that's something but
I I came to realize but on the as she
mentioned on the batal basis our
secretary has of the East African
Community in the last me meeting when he
was in EU I think he has also interacted
by with the EU uh commission to see the
way we can bring more private sector on
the side of the East African
Community and also the East African
Community have seen that they have now
done like one toward M Vis to make sure
that now you can first come tour and
know what's happening you do assessment
and do even through our East African
Business Council they are now trying to
interact with creating more forums so
that we can now interact and make sure
that you know the skills that the
African East Africans can give thank you
thank you so much I think you can also
talk to Bard about that uh trying to
assist German companies to break more
into the African Market uh yeah um there
are organizations working uh on making
that happen and we are hopeful that
these collaborations will succeed in
bringing them on the ground and
accrediation is very true for Germany so
we are uh working on it on this side the
other question was that he asked about
there are a lot of independent
professionals or groups around AI
Technology Innovation but they are not
part of Institutions such as yours so
what kind of linkage or how can you
create a linkage with all all these
groups that are working on Innovative
Technologies and that have access to the
market so they can actually enhance the
programs that you have I think that was
your second question
B
uh if I understood those kind
of integration it's about linkage
between the industry and the
universities so what we need is to First
identify them and at the universities
usually we have space for incubation if
they are small groups actually they can
be accommodated at the universities and
that could be a very good way of linking
them to the environment of the
University so we can work with them if I
understood the
question
yes
thank you any other question in the
group yes there's one
here I I actually have a comment um I
like your line of questioning and maybe
thought-provoking um yeah questions that
you have um my two comments are with
regard to Diaspora um contributions back
to the continent uh there's the element
of investment that is quite high from
diaspora that goes back to the continent
just to read a little bit we had in 2022
95 billion remittances going back to the
continent and out of that about 53
billion went to countries in sub Sahara
so we're talking about Ghana Kenya
Zimbabwe and the
rest and 29 billion went in no 30
billion in foreign direct Investments
and just 29 billion if you're comparing
the 95 billion to what got in through
maybe government um affiliations and um
foreign direct investment it was 30
billion 29 billion was uh came in in
terms of official development Aid to sub
Sahara so you can see that the African
diaspora really do give high amounts of
um there's a lot of high uh there's a
high remittance from African diaspora
and we look at it um in terms of the
risk of investment if African diaspora
can look at it at a different asset
class say angel investment that can be
very interesting to go into these
Innovations as we wait for governments
to come in and support innovations that
are going on in
research and where I see uh Academia
working more in private sector is um
looking at um research investment yes it
can come from private sector but also
what we were looking at was contract uh
private contract research contract
research where we can now employ the
expertise in Academia to go to private
sector I can give an example of AI that
whatever is going on on the continent
there's AI mapping of Innovations in
private sector going on and we can see
already that an institution such as
afrilabs is engaging ing academic staff
members to do that particular mapping
because they are good at it they
understand the technicalities of AI and
what um uh What uh technical outputs are
required in that field of study or that
field of implementation and then they
can also advise private sector but also
understand what are the needs that are
required for subject matter Mastery and
I really like the direction which we're
going to where PhD studies are now
getting the focus and the and the
attention that they deserve I really see
that uh in the next two years or even
immediately some of our work will go
into investing in further um like a more
in-depth studies and that will be phds
that is where the Innovations are
because then you understand what the
topic is all about then Innovations can
be B from there so in the next two years
we're seeing that that direction uh of
progress on our continent
yeah thank you so much so that means we
need an office that we can reach out to
in each of your institutions so maybe
like
diaspora info office at at your
universities or uh uh or institutions I
think that would be such a great idea
especially when you talk about investing
and Angel Investing I think that's a
very huge consideration from the
diaspora um well I'll follow up with
with questions and emails yeah so we can
make that
happen yeah any other questions in the
audience okay thank you mine will be
brief I would like to ask the engineer
what are some of the steps that your
organization is taking in so that they
can even help the students in the
universities with some of the practical
skills thank you
yeah uh thank you uh our organization as
East African Community one of the major
efforts they are doing is this
collaboration uh if you have seen there
is a center of excellence for the ICT
which is in the nelon Mandela that's one
of the region organiz I mean center of
excellence in the biomedical engineering
they have already established the
centers of excellence in which is
already situated inar there are several
centers of excellence the heart for the
medical side the kidy the cancer now the
mathematics so the region is coming
together to ensure that we put the
efforts together uh to ensure that at
least resources are optimized again
through the same organization from the
presentations you have been seeing there
is one common education area whereby the
free movement of students from one
country to another to access the the
resources that are already there has
already been harmonized to deliver that
if you are from Kenya and you go to
study in Tanzania or Randa or South
Sudan or Burundi you are paying the same
tution fee there is no more education
permit you are paying so that movement
the the movement itself has already been
achieved so the next thing is the
collaboration through now the bigger
institutions that are now going to do
the partnership so other things you saw
from the institution of the inter
University Council they are giving the
scholarships outside the uh within even
our region and Beyond to ensure that at
least our regional citizens are equipped
with enough resources so that's why we
are saying today that East African
Community is going to be the most moving
region because of the efforts they have
put in research
they have put also an Academia and also
the political will for the United East
Africa thank you thank you so much for
that we have five minutes so I just want
to give you each one second or two
second to have a closing statement about
what you want us to leave as your worth
where the hopes and dreams and you know
what do you wish for us to take as a
step uh action step I'll start with you
um my pting short for for this is to
leave you with uh by this saying that um
the East Africa region we are coming in
a positive way in a growth trajectory in
terms of issues of research and um
especially on advocacy on uh taking
research output to the market engaging
Partners both industry Partners
International partners and uh there are
very many institutional engagement
especially from Academia that are really
working and this is capped by the
positive policy directions that
governments within the regions are also
taking because uh there's need for the
policy
commitment and also implementation
levels at universities and also working
with um associations uh which are for
Innovation um especially Innovation hubs
which are there within the countries
they're also coming together and
engaging acad memic institutions so
positivity optimism we are in the growth
trajectory thank you Dr
salary oh thank you
ER what I want to say is that there's a
lot of talent in that region in East
Africa uh it's a lot of talented young
people I've seen them because I'm I'm
I'm working in the academic uh so what I
want want is a uh engage
I mean that the trust of the industry
the trust of the indust abroad like here
in Germany if they will invest on them
they will come to collaborate with them
for sure we look them very well because
we have a people and those people they
really need support and we have the
skill which I need here in Germany thank
you thank you so much for
you my last comment um is related to
uh the linkage between University and
the
companies uh as uh someone ask a
question on that I think it's important
for universities to involve companies in
training even in research because uh
companies are likely even to finance
researches it's important to do in this
direction and I think uh the regional um
uh Council as and coun uh for East
African Community is doing it's
important to uh to put together all uh
universities and in this way uh research
can be possible than University can can
act alone thank you thank you so much
last
one I appreciate for this opportunity I
would like to raise my voice to call for
the diasporas to as our ambassadors in
the countries the are especially in
Europe back in our countries we are
struggling to connect the our learning
institutions to give relevant education
by connecting with the industry so you
who are in the diaspora are the
ambassadors and the link direct to
Europe where the technology is very high
so please come back with the with the
with the purpose of connecting to the
higher learning institutions so that we
you open doors to those with great ideas
so they can also know what is going on
in this site and get connected to solve
the solutions for Africa amen thank you
so much for that uh thank you so much
African solutions for African problems
please speak give a hand to our
panelists it was really
insightful and with a little bit of
optimism collaboration Partnerships and
exchange of knowledge we believe that
this will be possible so I look forward
to what the next 5 10 years will be
bring uh because of this conversation so
thank you for joining us we're on
time maybe maybe we can take a group
photo here do you want to come and take
a group photo with us please come on
stage come on stage come on stage let's
take a group
photo here maybe we just need to move
those chairs back but I think some
people can stay here some people can
stand here in front
I'll be in the middle I'll be in the
middle my sister group picture group
picture take as a good
picture the on the
picture